québec leur avait promis une rentrée
sans masque une promesse à moitié
remplie les élèves pourront le retirer
en classe et aux services de garde mais
devront le porter dans les corridors les
aires communes et dans le transport
scolaire
les enseignants eux pourront le retirer
en fonction de la distance avec les
élèves on sait que les enfants sont
moins risque et la lionne balance des
inconvénients d'un plan qui équipe rude
mais un plat qui est responsable
c'est la variante delta qui joue les
trouble-fête en contrepartie le taux de
vaccination de 77% des 12 17 ans s est
tout de même québec à revenir à une
rentrée plus normal fini les groupes
classe fini également la distanciation
entre les élèves les activités
parascolaires seront autorisés pour tous
aux primaires et le passeport vaccinale
sera exigé pour celles jugées à haut
risque ou secondaire
un plan bien accueillie par les
principaux intéressés sauf que c'est
l'fun ce qui en moins de mesurer tout
l'année avec qui le faire avec les
sports j'ai déjà pas facile pour réseaux
tels que je pense que ça va être votre
bonus pour l'automne on espérait qu'ils
seraient rendus au printemps avec ça le
port du masque quelques minutes par jour
ce pas la fin du monde avec le
parascolaire aussi le sens ça va changer
beaucoup si la motivation pour certains
élèves et puis le gouvernement investit
13 millions de dollars dans un plan de
raccrochage scolaire on va se donner ce
que j'appelle un filet scolaire pour
empêcher les jeunes de tomber un agent
de liaison sera embauchée dans chaque
centre de services pour entrer en
contact avec les jeunes qui ont décroché
pendant la pandémie un jeune qui était
soit formation générale des jeunes
informations professionnelles
information générale aux adultes qui a
abandonné son projet scolaire recevra un
appel pour des gamins savons tous ce
plan est évidemment sujet des
ajustements avoir des changements si on
n'arrive pas à contenir la quatrième
vague le ministre est bien conscient
qu'il ne pourra pas empêcher d éclosion
en milieu scolaire mais il espère que
les mesures en place permettront
d'atténuer leur impact sur les élèves et
si valérie gamache radio canada
québec